The COO is a role of someone who
needs to be a jack of many trades and
a master of many trades.
That's a complex role.
It's someone who can drive operational
excellence, but also be able to understand
trends, create systems, put the resources
together to drive innovation.
The Emerging COO: Driving Innovation and
Operational Excellence is a program for
current or aspiring COOs.
It's a program that provides COOs
with frameworks to help them become
more effective and successful in this
complicated and multifaceted role.
Here at Stanford ,we are exceptionally
strong at teaching innovation,
and we're exceptionaaly strong
at teaching operations.
So we now have a framework that really
feeds the mindset of the COO and
can help COOs achieve those two objectives
that historically were viewed as separate.
Something that is unique
is this three month,
blended experience that is
broke into three modules.
We utilize a combination
of online learning,
face to face learning, and experiential
learning back to your organization.
But we begin with one month of
online experience with strategy and
basics of finance.
So our emerging COOs develop the language,
the vocabulary,
and the framework to be effective
partners with their CEO and their CFO.
Then we come here for a week,
building on those foundations, and
expanding on those foundations.
Then we bring in this notion of
operational excellence, innovation,
and how they come together through
a combination of case discussions and
experiential sessions.
And then at the end,
everyone will have the opportunity to take
an innovation slash operational
excellence challenge, work with a team
in their organization, tackle that
challenge using our frameworks and
our learnings with some support that
we can provide through that period.
Depending on where your organization is,
your role may be more focused on
the operational excellence piece or
the innovation piece.
So it's not like there
is one size fits all.
COOs, oftentimes they
are unrecognized heros
in the senior leadership
suite of organizations.
They are the builders,
the ones that work quietly behind
the scenes to make the organization work.
And this is a very optimistic
place with a can-do attitude.
COOs will find it hard
not to experience that.